let's define this word talent because
you could chuck in the one yeah
i mean
well i mean these days it's not much
because influence is all over the place
and they're saying the talent what i
would say what i'd say is anything that
anybody can do it's not it doesn't
require talent only fans is something
that anybody can do therefore you're not
talented to be an only friend
you could literally say anyone could be
an actor anyone could be a singer but
not anybody
can be not not anybody can like we use
johnny depp as an example yeah compared
to me
these are two top ranged people in their
industries one is clearly talented
just get banged on camera there's a
difference yeah i mean they're just
being banned on camera they're making
less you're trying to create nuances to
something that doesn't really exist is
it just it no she's getting banged okay
phone yes i should get banned on camera
but not every girl can do that someone
says he's talented every girl can get
back no no no it's not everything it's
hard work no like no not every girl
chooses to do that
but not every girl is going to stoop low
enough to do that i don't know if it's
about being low because it is low
because that's that's that's that's
some girls only with their boyfriends
and that's it
man and then no but these girls actually
do do that but even if you do it with
your boyfriends you're thinking short
term like because think about it those
girls are going to get married one day
is it to their boyfriends if it's not to
their boyfriends what's on the internet
forever then one day they're going to
have kids they're not thinking about
their kids yeah it's not a long term
thing but it's literally like at least
in today's society like everyone's very
money hungry and it's such a quick rich
scheme like it really why can't we be
money hungry you go to engineering
because you don't get the same amount as
you would like
but look at the example that we're
talking about we use mia khalifa as an
example we talked about the the
byproduct of participating in stuff like
sex michael leafy wants all the stuff
off the internet she's paid stupid
amounts of money to remove her stuff off
the internet and she still can't do it
and not only that it's harmed her
ability to stay in a long-term
relationship she wants to be she wants
to be in a long-term normal relationship
all the people keep doing this spam her
boyfriend with porn videos that she used
to do so now she's utterly speaking on
what she experienced in the industry and
she's letting girls know this is not
something that's conducive to successful
life so all this short term like fast
money comes with slow problems
and that's a fact so a lot of people are
sitting there thinking okay yeah
everyone's money hungry you still have
to do the right things to make that
money right and the wrong way to do
things well not everyone's getting
banged on camera some girls literally
just they're by themselves and they're
just but in lingerie cooking now not
everyone is going to those aren't the
big money makers but
i mean i don't know the taxes of only a
fan but not everyone has to have sex on
camera to make money from the only fans
or whatever they do but let's not talk
about exceptions to the rule yeah let's
let's be specific here most of the
people and only fans do it for sex work
right they're sex workers so most people
that are only fans do it for sex work
right yeah so let's stick to that
narrative then yeah instead of
just
like
like banging there's so much things to
say yeah sex work i'm talking about sex
work anything to do with sex work i'm
talking about okay fine all of it okay
cool ask a question
so if you were somebody who was very
attractive
not academic at school like struggled
with school
and maybe didn't have very much support
around you whether that's family or
friends and you saw that as a way to
like yeah alleviate your life into just
getting money quickly why doesn't she
marry rich
it's not bad easy not that
if they go 20 years older what the hell
they have they'll have so many guys
lined up to date even if i can marry a
50 year old even if they have no do you
want a wrinkly penis do it yeah do you
want money
do i want to be on the internet naked
forever
which one if i was that desperate i
would i would pick
but at least you feel like you have a
barrier like keyboard warriors you would
feel
potentially protected by the internet
because you're away from them they don't
have access to you protected at what
cost
yeah because most women who you go
through this like the
the um mental health is through the roof
like most people that do it most people
that are in don't want to be think that
the average um
death rate for women in that horizon
is corn it's like 36. so they're not
living happy lives like [ __ ] again fast
money slow problems
do you know what i feel like i feel like
in 2022
there's there's women that um yes don't
want to be in the industry of corn and
only fans but it's actually women that
want to be do this is that they actually
enjoy their jobs oh they do they're
addicted to attention and yeah but i'm
saying not everyone's coming from even
fact of like you know has no family or
what have you that these some people
have come from established homes and
there's something they enjoy doing well
they yeah because they don't want to
work
they'd rather they'd rather take the
easy way out than get a job like men do
or like anyone else's i think as well
though a lot of jobs nowadays they're
seeing the pay comparison to say like an
engineer right the same work in a month
on only fans and they're saying why am i
studying for a degree where i could
literally just get shirtless in a second
and selfishly and like
i guess but then at the point it's
literally like is self-respect more than
six figures at this point it's like what
is self-respect to that point do you
know why it is here because you have to
think like everybody's thinking short
term yeah in a long time
if we look at our athletes for this
example most athletes have to retire
most of them will retire around 30.
i think it's 80 percent of them go broke
you're talking about these only fans
people who make a fast amount of money
without building the mentality of how to
manage that money you're going to lose
that money so then you're effectively in
a worse place than you started so then
at least if you have your self-respect
you've got a basis or a foundation to
start from if you go into only fans put
yourself out there lose your social
capital and your respect and then you're
broke as well you're just the biggest
loser in society and and it's legacy one
day you're going to be 70 60. like we're
going to live to be 90 most of us
what's the second half of your life
going to look like probably alone if you
did only fans 100 oh okay that's um
that's very shocking
okay okay
let me ask the man let me ask the men um
would you wife a girl that does only
fans don't even there's no point even
ask you that question okay
[Laughter]
just because of my standards though but
i'm trying to play devil's advocate just
to keep but honestly like for me
i want it at least me like very intimate
and i for me it loses its intimacy if
everyone else has seen everything else
that is my prized possession not my that
sounds really weird like do you know i
mean like it's your human
companion so like if i know my human
companions just everything is everywhere
it it loses intimacy because like you
think like i'm not naked in front of you
lot but i'd be naked in front of my man
like do you know what i mean i think it
just loses
personally but obviously other people
have different stuff like a lot of
people in our age now have open
relationships they don't need that
intimacy but for me
i like knowing like the only person
who's seen my man's clothes off is me
and vice versa but other people don't
really care it's literally just people
standing there the lesser there is or
something the more valuable valuable it
becomes so if the thing is give it out
to everybody again it holds no value but
if you want something that everything
yeah yeah it's like most people buy
brand new phones you don't go to the
shop to buy a second-hand phone you want
something brand new do you get what i'm
saying
well i think
i mean i understand where everyone's
coming from but um the the fact of the
matter is the option is there for them
you know yeah we live in this we live in
a den age where
there's there's plenty of opportunity to
make money whether or not it's the right
choice or not that comes down to
what you believe in
and so on and so forth but
i don't like to downplay anyone's hustle
because it's been done yeah
yeah so people look at me and think oh
you're a professional footballer okay
but that's easy you just kick a ball
around that's it
when it's not it's actually a lot a lot
that goes into it so whether i'd whether
or not i agree with um being on only
fans and uh being a sex worker just on
the other but i still feel like they are
working for it and if there's a market
for it
so i have a question how many years did
you train to be a professional
footballer
[Laughter]
no it's a great question um
i mean i started
my dad started training at the age of
six
and then
yeah and then i got scouted at 12 and
then
um
16 until so
most of my life i've been okay